hey 42 here this is two stunning 13th
century cathedral of santa maria del
fiore in florence italy an s is a modern
take on a cathedral in liverpool built
in the 60s this is the oldest shopping
mall in italy the galleria vittorio
emanuele ii in milan built in 1865
similarly this is the beautiful
cleveland arcade in ohio built in 1888
and this monstrous bastard is a Tesco in
Woollett England this is two striking
Moscow State Historical Museum in the
Red Square
whereas this is an over art museum in
grouse Austria that looked like a
bacteria you find in your guts this is
of course the fantastic Art Deco Empire
State Building in New York and this is
the soul-destroying
ver eyes on building also in New York
notice a difference between these
examples why is it that anything built
post-war from shopping arcades to
libraries are desperately
soul-destroying lee oakley you don't
have to go into cities to notice this
trend simply look around it's your
neighborhood you may notice that some
houses are strikingly beautiful like
this this or this whereas others may
look like this or god forbid this then
you realize the differences that the
previous houses were built
pre-war usually in the Georgian and
Victorian eras the oakley buildings most
definitely post-war in the Victorian age
people were proud of their homes they
built they put every effort into sorting
their highest quality materials to
ensure they would last for centuries
post-war houses however started to be
built primarily for profit the beauty
and quality were shoved aside for
smaller land plots smaller rooms lower
ceilings cheaper materials and shortcuts
such as cavity walls statistically the
average lifespan of houses has decreased
over the decades the average lifespan of
a masonry and wood building
120 years a concrete and glass building
is half that at sixty years I know what
you might say the beauty is in the eye
of the beholder
I disagree taste is subjective but raw
beauty is an objective almost measurable
quality Plato said the objective
education is to teach us to love what is
beautiful if we have to learn what is
beautiful that invariably means not
everything is beautiful
for example nobody would ever say dog
excrement is beautiful unless they're
trying to shock you and just because one
weirdo out there has a personal liking
for the appearance of doctored does not
make it an objectively beautiful
creation the fact is that certain things
are just objectively damn ugly and give
the majority of the population no
pleasure in fact some things are so ugly
they make entire populations depressed
and the statistic back me up here
people living in cities are 21 percent
more likely to have anxiety disorder and
if you grew up in a city you're 39
percent more likely to develop
schizophrenia than your contemporaries
in the countryside to me the reason
behind these statistics is obvious
humans evolved amongst a raw unordered
beauty of nature for the 200,000 years
Homo sapiens have walked the earth
we have only been living inside man-made
houses for roughly 6,000 of those it's
almost axiomatic that a structure which
imitates nature will be more comforting
to our evolved sensibilities as human
beings and I don't mean like an
ostentatiously metaphorical architect
such as this concrete slab of a building
compliment to major it sits in because
it features a vertical extrusion which
allows the light to soften its edges see
how it almost disappears into the
surroundings no when I say buildings
that reflect nature make us happier I am
referring to two distinct facets that
achieve this symbiosis the first is the
material a building is made from stone
is
natural we evolved among stone our
ancestors fashion tools and use them to
chip away beautiful masterpieces out of
a natural material that had always been
there
similarly wood has always been an
intrinsic part of the human experience
one thousand years ago the planet used
to be peppered with forests as far as
the eye could see in all directions
stone and wood buildings are usually
rather attractive however modern
materials such as glass steel and
concrete are all man-made
they are amalgamations of other
materials over the vast timeline of
human history
these artificial materials have only
very recently entered our world before
we knew it they were frost into our
faces in every direction we turn glass
steel and concrete tower many metres
above us we never evolved amongst these
materials they make us feel uneasy the
glass is of course the least offensive
if the Treo because it allows us to see
through it to their natural world beyond
the second facet that creates beautiful
architecture is curves and detail curves
and intricate details are in art form
long lost to the world of modern
architecture which inexplicably favors
arrow straight lines and huge flat
planar surfaces many meters wide curves
are natural the bend of a tree bark the
undulation of meadows these are
qualities we have evolved to feel
comfortable amongst humans have a
fundamental proclivity to adorn the
chaotic beauty of mother nature's great
Kingdom straight lines and huge flat
surfaces make us feel uneasy like a
stark white wall there is no comfort to
be found in it only emptiness and
solitude one only needs to look at the
curves present in classic Greek columns
so eerily reminiscent of the golden
ratio or the seemingly infinitely
masterful details precisely carved into
the masonry of great European cathedrals
to appreciate curves in architecture and
see the obvious inspiration
drawn from nature compare these to any
inner-city office block with its
suffocatingly one-dimensional surfaces
he'll Londoners are so abhorred by the
disgusting array of lifeless towers of
Tosh erected in their city they have
taken to inventing humorous nicknames
for them all in a desperate attempt to
inject some life into their dead souls
they call this one the cheese grater
this is the Pringle they sister helter
skelter this is the walkie-talkie
this is the armadillo this the
saltcellar and this is the gherkin which
is caught on so well at literally
everyone has forgotten what is such one
namers which by the way is 30 Street
Mary Axe Wow I think I'll stick to the
gherkin a you ghost survey found that a
whopping 77 percent of respondents
prefer traditionally designed buildings
over contemporary the real reason why
most people hate modern architecture is
that it disrespects our heritage
humanity has come a long way and the
things we have achieved over the past
5,000 years are incredible the great
civilizations along the way
Constantinople ancient Greece Rome
medieval London these are the
civilizations that built the world we
know today and for Humanity to ever
forget that would be an odious act of
treachery but that's exactly what modern
architecture seeks to do by simplifying
and foregoing ornamentation and frescoes
it erases the triumphs of the past from
our greatest oldest cities and thus the
public consciousness most of all we
adore traditional architecture because
it subtly connects us with the past it
reminds us of our lineage each and every
day and the achievements we have made as
a collective human race over the
centuries so who do we have to thank for
wanting to erase humanities achievements
off the face of the planet
why did architects all over the world
wake up after World War one
think I'm going to start designing
buildings utter [ __ ] eclis well I'm
afraid we have to blame a Swiss
Frenchman named Luca Busia who created a
deadly Maxim he wanted to create
architecture made of pure shapes and
forms without any decoration or
historical associations Luca Busia
actually drew up plans for a city for
three million people who wore lived in
identical six-story great skyscrapers if
our ancestors wanted us to live in great
boxes they could have just surrendered
to the Germans
kibou Z and those who followed in his
dreadful wake thought that function came
before form how a building looked it was
a far less importance than how it
functions off the back of caboose ia's
ideology were born the schools of new
architectural styles such as Soviet
constructivism Bauhaus functionalism or
utilitarianism structuralism and
Brutalism within a few decades our once
beautiful cities turned into wastelands
of repugnancy devoid of beauty and taste
so his modern architecture always a bad
thing for ultra-modern cities that
didn't even exist or what not large
cities 100 years ago such as Dubai in
Singapore
perhaps not these places have a tinge of
futurism to them which gives them an
exciting edge but the absolute worst
crime of modern architecture when it
really gets my goat when it actually
damages civilizations eradicate Beauty
is when it is placed amongst truly
marvelous and historic cities and Paris
is often said to be the most beautiful
city in the world under Napoleon's
orders in 1853 Georges Eugene Hausman
redesigned and rebuilt a devastated post
revolution Paris from the ground up he
was responsible for the seductively
quaint ornate houses the grand
boulevards and
relaxing public squares it's romantic
splendor has attracted millions each
year to soak in the beauty and then in
1969 some sadist plunked this right in
the middle of it all
the tour montparnasse like a scab on an
otherwise attractive city skyline
London one of the oldest unn culturally
richest cities in the world which made
it through plagues and fire is now being
destroyed by dreadfully dull tower
blocks like the painfully ugly Trellick
Tower the Luftwaffe may have flattened
our cities but in their place we rebuilt
concrete and steel monstrosity that
transformed what was once beautiful into
an urban dystopian sprawl that wouldn't
be out of place in a George Orwell novel
Birmingham is a prime example before the
Blitz it was an attractive testament to
the great civilization it played a part
in building now the entire city centre
feels like a purposeless amalgamation of
offensive drab architecture placed
randomly without care or consideration
and the worst offender at the center of
it all is this modernist mole the
Birmingham library but you may think if
it provides housing then why does it
matter because people don't care about
ugly things these buildings are so
visually offensive that people have no
desire to actually look after them the
neighborhoods that spring up around
tower blocks more often than not reflect
the building's themselves why not
because the people that have to live
inside them are any different from
people who live in attractive houses
they just feel as though there's nothing
worth looking after the value of period
houses is significantly higher for the
same square footage than new builds
despite requiring much more maintenance
humans are drawn towards and have a need
to preserve beauty
if we build beautiful houses and
beautiful public buildings then people
will fight to preserve them and so will
our ancestors whereas ugly buildings get
run down
and very quickly abandoned then
demolished ironically this costs a lot
more in the long run instead of building
for the next generation we are building
cheaper or clearer constructions for our
short-term use knowing they will one day
be pushed to the side because nobody
wants to bloody live in the
monstrosities and it will fall into
dilapidation then inevitably demolished
ugliness is false economy and beauty is
eternal Rome's Colosseum is almost 2,000
years old
why because nobody over the span of two
millennia had the heart to destroy such
beauty such magnificence sure half of it
has crumbled away but that only serves
as a testament to its compelling power
to want to save what still remains do
you really think in 2,000 years time
urban tower blocks will still be here
and have millions spent on them each
year for the hair preservation if a
concrete tower block starts to crumble
into the dirt we quickly send the entire
thing crashing down with explosives
because that's what we think of it the
Pantheon is just as old and in even
better condition form does not come
after function I never heard so much
pitch in all my life it's actually the
opposite form is everything we don't
venerate the works of Shakespeare
because they're functional his writings
are beautiful if function was more
important than form that students would
instead study vacuum cleaner manuals in
English literature nobody will fight to
preserve something that is ugly but has
function whereas whole nations will burn
together to defend a beautiful building
with absolutely no function whatsoever
tourism aside what function does the
Colosseum serve us today none whatsoever
we aren't keeping it around just in case
society wakes up one morning and decides
to throw a few
politicians in there with a couple of
bears its function is to be admired to
be respected and most importantly to
connect us to our past because it's that
past that makes us who we are and
architecture never lets us forget that
it gives us our identity our sense of
place and purpose and dare we destroy
that or mask it at our own peril if you
want to do your part in making the world
a more beautiful place then a great
place to start is by learning design
skills on Skillshare Skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands
of classes in illustration art design
and more Premium Membership gives you
unlimited access to high-quality classes
on must know topics so you can improve
your skills unlock new opportunities and
do the work you love you could make your
own living space better by watching the
skill share course interior design
basics simple steps to your perfect
space or if you fancy improving the
world for others then you could learn
the digital illustration skills required
to become an architect by taking the
course mastering Illustrator 10 tips on
tricks to speed up your work for skill
share is really affordable an annual
subscription is less than ten dollars a
month since Skillshare sponsoring this
video the first 500 people to use the
promo link in the description will get
their first two months for free thank
you for watching and thanks again to
Skillshare for sponsoring this video be
sure to check them out by using the link
below